good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy thursday that feels
like a friday but it's not a friday but
we're getting so close
i can't even complain we're so close
we're this close y'all and not only is
it thursday we are over the hump
but the hump himself is here bringing
smiles and cheer
wherever he is near theo is joined with
us in studio today he could not be here
yesterday because i had to record my
audiobook for five hours
after the show yesterday and it was hard
you know the first session i was like
breezing through it like i was just like
my mouth was connected with my brain and
last session i was like
dude everyone was like what happened to
this girl
so it's okay we're making progress
pre-order is available at
girlsnowjob.com
book audio book ebook and print
hardcover whatever they call it
is available so check it out five hours
uh-huh i've been sitting on that joke
since you said it legally blonde stands
you know
oh in the hot tub five hours got it
you might notice that jack and i are
matching today because we are debuting
another
piece of merch this is a brand new
holiday design our toasty and bright
sweatshirt jackie is wearing the black
crew neck in a size
medium and i am wearing a new color a
maroon which i'm living for
um hoodie in the size extra large
and also our toasty and bright holiday
design also comes in phone cases if i
could get a close-up on my camera
this fabulous sleek phone i love that
phone case that's the phone case i used
last week and a mug because you know i'm
just feeling thirsty and
we've got lots of tea to sip today and i
also feel like it's gonna be
a little more challenging than usual to
get into the holiday spirit this season
but with all of these merch and
accessories like
you'll be feeling toasty and bright
throughout the season and you know what
jackie look at me i'm gonna start a
petition to keep like the holiday fever
going like
through march because you shouldn't be
like suffering through january through
march like without that
wintry spirit the thing is is that like
the the depression after like january
1st
is so real because you just come off of
like the halloween thanksgiving
christmas new year's hanukkah kwanzaa
hype
and that hype is like this this
immaculate vibe
it's not even like it's not tangible how
you feel during the holiday season it's
just like a little sparkle fairy dust
set over
these two months and even if we all
collectively decided to like keep that
vibe till march like
you can't just like create the vibe
what's so special about it is like you
know that the holiday season is like
once a year and it comes and goes so
fast
and that's what makes it so immaculate i
agree but because this year is unlike
any year we've ever experienced before i
think we can change some things up
some things that you never would have
changed i'm so here for the optimism i'm
just
trying to like lay the groundwork for
reality unfortunately
okay well reality doesn't need to set in
for a while merch drops
tomorrow you guys we have all these
items we've been wearing we have other
stuff
like that we'll post on our instagram
we're gonna wear tomorrow like some
super holiday christmasy vibe also just
like super morning toast five i was
wearing
this new um sweatsuit that we made that
oh i was wearing it last night too um
yeah i wore it all day yesterday i
think officially it's my favorite piece
of merch
i just like don't want it i don't want
to throw that out there so lightly i
think the rda sweatshirt is my favorite
piece of merch just because it's a new
color yellow which i love and rdh is
just like a
you know a cause that's really close to
my heart yeah no it's it's a beautiful
thing it's a beautiful sweatshirt
you guys will see all of the designs
we'll post them on our instagram so you
can shop tomorrow
shopmorningtoast.com 10 30 a.m eastern
time
maybe set an alarm because there is
limited inventory we wanted everyone to
be able to get their items
immediately immediately so check it out
shopmorningtoast.com and in case you you
forgot like when it's dropping let me
hear you with a song
tomorrow
[Music]
you're wrapping me up oh sorry sorry
keep going like it was good but i need
you to lay it in over i finish my vocals
do you know okay no i'm sorry i don't
understand someone like not being able
to juggle multiple vocal abilities so
i'm sorry it's just taking me a long
time tomorrow
[Music]
did you hear what i was doing i was
trying to check out a-e-i-o-u
instead of being like a oh i was like
that's a great song that's such a good
ted reference i loved head so much
i loved it i was just talking with
someone this weekend about how ted is
just a fantastic movie
add it to the content one and two no i
was out today make sure you do not add
two because two
does not work on the basic premise that
mark wahlberg and mila kunis were otp in
the first year like there was no reason
that they had to that they could have
been broken up like honestly unless she
died they should have killed her off
yeah because to see him be like otp with
another woman it's like we all remember
what happened the beauty of that
relationship was weird
on those grounds what of all that we
have so many like ted jokes that are
like ingrained in our dna because we've
been saying them for so long
what do you think is your favorite ted
joke um
i went to new york once in 1989 and i
did not feel safe i feel like yours
is fresh cakes oh my god fresh cakes is
such a big part of my life every time we
change our sheets um we call them fresh
cakes
and like everything urinal cakes
everything is fresh cakes i think my
favorite
joke is i married the wrong woman
and now i lead a life of regret no it's
um
are you alone well you know one's never
alone when you're with christ
so if you haven't seen ted by the way
get on that and maybe watch ted too
there is one redeeming moment in ted two
when ted does the voice over to the law
and order theme song
oh yeah and he's like we're a bunch of
[ __ ] who take up the entire hallway
with our walk
like it's so funny and actually you know
a friend of mine
has ted original original bear ted
that he got isn't that crazy i've seen
ted
and you haven't stolen it because no i
know it's like it's not really that
important to him but like every time i'm
over at his house i'm like
i don't know if you know like what this
bear means to me no like like if my
friend loves me he'll give me ted for my
birthday
i love that's so true i know and i feel
like in this very special way theo
is named after ted 100 teddy theodore
theodora theodora
you know we have a lot of tick tock
drama to discuss today and we were
actually like talking about it before
the cameras went up and
um it's really interesting but there is
like another tick tock saga that's
taking over my life and i need to fill
you in on it because i feel like you
don't know
what number seven no okay that's not
what i thought you were gonna say
so there is this video that went viral
and it's just so funny and we were
talking about this literally last week
how there hasn't been like a genuine
like organic viral moment
in so long like alex from target and
motion spray from target is like
what's the word small
change next to like what an actual viral
no but what i meant
is like alex from target was the most
random seemingly
like mundane piece of content that
happened to go viral like
the the ocean spray dreams video was
like funny and like it's
it's not mysterious why it went viral
okay
but it's like those seemingly like
nothing moments that go viral like damn
daniel like people couldn't believe how
big it became
that's what's happening on tick tock
right now there's this football team
based in michigan and i don't know the
high school or whatever
um and i guess they like won a game and
their videographer filmed them after the
game in the locker room doing their like
post show ritual
and i guess like the team is obsessed
with the song eenie meenie by king
sean kingston and justin bieber's
[ __ ] good song eeny meeny miny
and there's just this moment leading up
to the chorus where like these guys
these in the still in their football
gear are like
singing the song and there's like one
number seven who's like really the star
of the video and he's like so handsome
and i feel weird because he's like
literally 16 years old
and they just like vibe so hard to the
song and it was just this clip that
environment this kid
people know everything about him already
he's his name is kaden he's
committed to harvard for football he's
like really really good at football he's
up for like michigan football player of
the year
um he has a girlfriend people have found
out and he made a tick tock last night
like he didn't even have a tick tock
account he made a tick tock account like
has a million followers already and like
recreated the video with his friends on
the tennis court
and it got like 15 million views and i'm
just like obsessed with this saga
because i love
i love the reason that this video went
viral for no other reason the fact that
like these guys were just like vibing
yeah i got to see the original video you
do i'll send it to you it's just such
like an
interesting saga to follow cool i
wouldn't call that tic tac drama though
because no i didn't say drama did i i
feel like you did you said i feel like
you remember like a little too much you
know
you're always just [ __ ] like no
because honestly i was waiting for like
the dramatic part because i think it was
framed it could like the tick tock drama
we're going to report on today that's
actual drama
no it's just i think i believe i use the
word saga maybe you misheard me but
i just need you to stop like remembering
things it's really [ __ ] annoying and
i just realized like if we were all
superheroes you would be like the
rememberer
that's funny claudia that's funny it's
annoying
i mean sorry but you said it i don't
think i feel like bronwyn like i want to
apologize
like you said it did you just call me
shannon i did i mean
she totally said it there is absolutely
no doubt in my mind that shannon said it
um speaking of we're going to recap
orange county and salt lake city tonight
salt lake city it's just
really turning out to be something of
the storm something of the sort heather
gay was on watch travel side with
shannon maduro and it was just like an
immaculate duo
oh nice i couldn't make it to watch what
happens live because my content plate
ended at midnight last night
yeah i watched two more episodes of the
crown or maybe three
i'm gonna finish it tonight i think i
have two more and then we'll discuss it
tomorrow does that work for you
but like my thoughts are gone like we'll
bring them back we'll resurrect the
thoughts
okay it's just like annoying like we had
a plan you know like no you went rogue
we said by the end of the week and then
you watch them in one night sorry
they're just like
so good i know i'm just like my schedule
hasn't been conducive
yeah salt lake city is really really
good um wish we could say the same about
orange county
we have some things to discuss about the
programming we yeah situation
yeah on the morning toast and we'll
discuss it in the tv recap segment which
is after the fast five
yeah so i think without further ado we
could get right into the past five
stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and by the way i know that tomorrow like
our rdh sweaters are gonna go
fly off the shelves so in case you feel
rdh about it not getting the rdh sweater
stick with me here i'm here i'm with you
um by your side
i have a cure for your potential future
rda take us there claude
today's episode is brought to you by
liquid iv flu season is right around the
corner and the winter months approaching
it is more important than ever to have a
strong immune system
when you're pushing your body hard or
feeling run down it's really important
to take care of yourself
with the proper vitamins and nutrients
that's why liquid iv
created the hydration multiplier plus
immune support to maintain and
strengthen your immune system
having good immunity as like you grow up
and like you become an adult and like
everything hurts
is really you realize the most important
thing so if you could take something
every day from liquid ivy
that boosts your immunity why wouldn't
you it's a cutting edge blend of vitamin
c
vitamin d zinc wellmune and they come in
convenience single serve packets
vitamin c is well known to protect your
body and support good health vitamin d
facilitates
immune system function and improves your
daily defense each packet is bursting
with fresh natural tangerine flavor it
tastes so good i've been putting them
in my water um almost every morning for
the last two weeks then i definitely
find myself waking up feeling better
um so if there's just like one thing you
could do just like put it in your water
like to make you feel better
boost your immunity like why wouldn't
you do that totally when you purchase
liquid iv
you're also joining the mission to help
people live better lives with every
purchase liquid iv donates a serving of
liquid iv to someone in need
they are donating 3.7 million servings
in response to cobin 19.
their products are being donated to
hospitals first responders food banks
veterans and active military
so you could buy from liquid liquid iv
knowing you're going to feel good
physically
and emotionally because you're helping
out liquid iv's new hydration multiplier
plus immune support
is available at walmart or online if you
want to get 25
off online go to liquidive.com and use
the promo code toast at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order from
their website at liquidive.com
when you use the promo code toast get
better hydration at liquidity.com
promo code toast love it sign on feel
good
physically and emotionally yeah first
story
the aforementioned tick-tock drama
tick-tock stars charlie and dixie dimlio
are in a little bit of hot water so
charlie and dixie are facing
fierce backlash for their quote
appalling table manners and rude
treatment
of their personal chef after they made
faces and gagging noises
as they ate a meal he had prepared with
one of them even dramatically running
outside to throw up
in the debut video for their new dinner
with the demilio series that is being
featured on their recently launched
youtube
family channel the tick tock tick tock
stars sat down with their parents mark
and heidi
and their first mystery guest who was
youtube star and beauty influencer james
charles
the episode has been trending on youtube
since it was shared on monday
but many people were less than impressed
by what they saw critics have been
taking to the comments to call out
charlie who was 16
and dixie who is 19 for their behavior
with many insisting that james charles
was the only one with any table manners
i actually agree
people are calling them brats they're
calling them rude
quote disgusting um
and they're in a bit of of hot water
well what i find really interesting and
i think what i've learned
spending so much time on tick tock with
like the gen z community is that
gen z is very pro cancel culture like
and i think it's because they're like
super young and don't like have enough
experience in life
to understand like giving people grace
and like forgiveness and honestly i feel
like maybe i was that way too when i was
younger
um so it's weird this is just a
fascinating situation for me as someone
who's like obsessed with just like
the culture around cancer culture um
because i
i watched the video and their behavior
was bad like you can't deny like they
were acting like
rats and just like rude in front of a
person who cooked you a meal like
why don't you talk [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
the food like behind everyone behind his
back like you know like normal people
but it was very like subtle almost and i
just found it interesting that so much
like gen z really picked up on this i
feel like when people get cancelled
in this day and age it's like really
overt like they said something really
bad
but i find i found their behavior to be
bad but like
i don't know i don't know if i just i'm
shocked like so many people picked up on
it you know what i mean
yeah i just i watched some of the clips
that you showed me and honestly
they're acting like children because
they are children and this is what
happens when children become
dinner yeah um i don't think that
they're going to be cancelled over this
i think that there's like backlash and
we saw that dixie put out a video trying
to
to explain the context of the situation
saying that it was taken out of context
because everyone knows that like she
gets very turned off by a lot of foods
they intentionally like put snails in
front of her and like the chef was in on
it
and that's why she went and threw up
apparently like everything makes her
throw up
that wasn't a part of the video that
sort of context and they are the ones
who put out the video so like
if it doesn't work without that bit of
information you could have added that it
wasn't like they were caught on camera
right so like i thought at first the
video was on james charles's channel
which made sense like the demilio family
didn't have like you know final cut on
on the end and
he wouldn't have been prioritizing how
they look
right it would be himself but then when
it came to find when i i actually ended
up going to their channel finding the
video and like watching the first few
minutes
um and the whole thing to me like
i i found the parents behavior to be
also kind of weird
because if you're if you're acting that
way in front of guests and camera like
that's because you act that way at home
and like you're not reprimanded for it
like as a child so
i i just it was just it's just a weird
they're not bad people by any means it
was just like a really bad look which
everyone has and that's just a part of
being famous especially when you became
famous
virtually overnight but the timing is
just not great because charlie
um was like hours away from reaching 100
million followers she was at 99.5
and now she's at 98.9 so this is like a
significant
thing going on yeah but i'm sure she'll
just reach 100 in like two days instead
of one
day yeah i i do think it's interesting
that people put picked up on it you know
yeah but ultimately like i don't think
it's a huge deal and you have to
remember like that these are
kids kids like charlie is literally 16
like how are you behaving when you were
16 especially
if they like you could make the argument
oh they behave this way on camera what
are they like when the cameras aren't
there
or you can make the argument like the
other cameras there so they were putting
on trying
they thought that this was like a funny
bit you know we're gonna like
vomit the snails and right this chef
dixie had said like they've been working
with him for months and he's like a
close family friend
that she knew his feelings wouldn't be
hurt like you know i i just
yeah we must keep in mind that these are
children children whose lives have
dramatically changed in the last year
they're literally living in a mansion in
la with a personal chef
now and they were just living you know
in the suburbs of connecticut last year
so like
let's give them a little grace but i do
find it interesting that their parents
are
so involved in their business like
professionally um almost to a point
that's like kind of weird like
but even with their parents being so
like heavy-handed no one
foresaw this like maybe not making them
look good like how many people have
watched this video before it went
to their channel yeah and like nobody
thought
oh the girls like don't come off right
here and the parents
as far as i know have been so involved
in their girls careers like making tick
tocks for themselves and making a family
youtube channel
to look out for the girls because the
girls are 16 and 19 and are now like
some of the biggest stars in the world
so
if you're really doing all that to look
out for them how did this go
yeah and it's also interesting when
people get famous from like
instagram or tick tock where it's like
15 second clips or even a minute clips
you really don't get a sense of
someone's personality
but then sometimes people venture into
say podcasting or launching a youtube
channel and it's like
how that translates to a longer form
sometimes 15 seconds is enough it's more
than enough yeah no so i'll be uh
interested to see how this plays out gen
z can be really rough
so let's just remember that they're
children yeah
okay next up we have some real estate
news two stories that i think you might
find interesting celeb real estate
okay sorry i don't i didn't mean like
real estate okay douglas element
first up the kardashian family's fake
reality tv home which we spoke about
this week
is on sale for seven point nine nine
million dollars it's the
house that is always showed as quote
chris's house it's like tan
brownish yes although she's never
actually lived there i think it was on
sale a few years ago too because i
remember
it coming on the market and now it's on
the market again for 7.9
million it's a beautiful home if anybody
wants to buy it invite us over we would
love to come
i actually wonder if the kardashians
like using this house and promoting it
so much
increases or decreases the value of the
whole increases because if you think
you would think maybe decreases because
it's like security so visible blah blah
blah but like think of like
famous tv homes like the full house home
like yeah
if it was ever i think it's like a i
think it's almost like a landmark now
yeah no it's like an airbnb or something
right if that were to ever go for sale
like it would be worth so much
like the brady home yeah yeah that's
true so i think ultimately
it's in the plus column okay so i just
thought that was some interesting real
estate news though
it was another real estate celebrity
news story which i just saw that i
thought was interesting
star wars actress billy lorde is
combining her mother
lords and star wars yeah apparently i
think they mean scream
queens i do think that they mean that
too they obviously just got their wife
is combining her mother carrie fisher's
home and her grandmother demi
debbie reynolds hollywood properties
together to create an 18 million
mega estate following the birth of her
son so first of all i didn't know that
they lived next to each other mom and
daughter live next to each other so cute
billy's bringing them together i think
this is just like some big wig news
wow look at billy just like making moves
making the states
i wonder if she's going to put them
together and then sell or live there
it seems like a lot of land for a lot of
house for one woman for three people
yeah i don't know i just feel like you
can never have enough land
i i feel that way too but this would be
like a good business venture for her but
i'm not sure she wants to sell her
grandparents and parents home i don't
know sometimes it's it's too
painful that's true but i feel like
homes are if you have enough money to
like restore like your childhood home
your grandparents i'm like make it into
a palace like
you would never sell that you know yeah
it is a dream it's a dream
so it'll be interesting to see what she
does but that's really cool i like that
idea a lot like yeah that's definitely
something i would do if i
had two statements i just happened to be
next if you inherited two estates that
yeah that share land border do they say
what part of town it's in
um beverly hills ooh sweet
that that is exciting the truckers for
tasha are here the truckers for billy
truckers for billy we love them okay
next story a little royal news i'll let
you get your crown
fixed because meghan markle admits
giving personal information
to the finding freedom authors duh like
oh my god i read literally two chapters
of this book it sounds like billy eilish
no it's like no [ __ ] sherlock i read two
uh chapters it was literal propaganda
yeah
meghan markle has reportedly admitted to
giving personal information to the
authors of finding freedom the tell-all
book that details her and prince harry's
exit from the british royal family
marco spilled her own tea to the authors
in order to ensure her side of the story
was included
the telegraph reported on wednesday
according to the docs lodged with the
high court marco revealed that she was
worried her father's narrative about her
including that she had allegedly
abandoned him might be included in the
book
therefore she presented her own version
of events to a source to pass along
so the true position could be
communicated to the authors to prevent
any further misrepresentation
is working on meghan markle's pr team is
like so meticulous it's like yes she did
this but here's a full strategy as to
why she did it because the father like
of like of course no one really takes
her dad's claims
seriously he's like fodder for the back
page of the daily mail like
nobody really cares and i don't think
it's a big deal that meghan markle gave
um her side of the story to the
autobiographers because
it makes it helpful like it's but it is
against the rules
yeah and i feel like also either it's an
official
story or it's an unofficial you know
fans retelling
fanfiction and then when it's like okay
so she shared information about
her dad to clear up any misinformation
then it's like
okay but did she share anything else
like now it's like they they were on
email
the door like what else she gave her
opinion on
yeah did what episode of the crown are
you up to so i just finished an episode
where um
i'm oh i'm oh the margaret thatcher
queen
48 against one in the comments the
commonwealth and
uh dumb question and like i'm really
embarrassed to ask
is the commonwealth still like a group
it's a great question and i believe that
it is okay it's such a nice idea
yeah it is a nice idea okay did you get
to the episode yet where the queen gives
a statement
on oh that's the episode yes and it
reminds me of this episode where like
the queen doesn't speak but she spoke
you know
right do you think that the crown
obviously took like a hard
side here saying like they believed the
queen did release the statement and it
wasn't like some rogue publicist
do you believe that i i i'm inclined to
believe the crown
you know i'm like finish the season and
i'm like less and less inclined to
believe them they took like a
very to leave the the the show the show
that's what i mean when i say believe
the crown like i
i was believing the show no so was i but
i feel like this season for the first
time especially towards the end like
i feel like they were more
they took more freedom with like their
narrative
and were kind of making the crown look
bad like in a lot of ways
taking sides they like when it comes to
the diana stuff they unequivocally took
diana's side
and i'm actually going to watch royal
house of windsor because someone
recommended to me as like
the most accurate retelling of what went
down between charles and diana
they say diana in her words well of
course it's going to be diana's side so
i want to watch
something impartial and i feel like i
never can get anything impartial like i
just know that there's more to it
than like him being in love with camilla
like i just know it yeah and
even in the lead up like that
conversation where diana goes to the
queen and like is giving her a hug and
calling her
like just wants to be loved that didn't
happen yeah i just feel like i could see
it
leading up to them taking diana's side
yeah and they're not even making the
crown look bad but more so
charles which 100 like charles's fault
no matter what like you can't but i just
felt like in so many different instances
and
especially in an episode coming up about
like extended members of the royal
family
i really feel like they're like trying
to make the crown look the monarchy look
bad this season
but that i think i watched royal house
of windsor because i remember
after watching the crown i just wanted
like more and more and
i think it was in there where they said
it was charles and we're seeing this now
who
trimmed the royal family down to just
like the the uh
nucleus and just the people in the line
of succession like well that's good
because there's so many people and
literally so many episodes are like
margaret not knowing what to do with her
life and not knowing what to do with her
life and like honestly
when oh you didn't get there but they
call charles calls
prince andrew fringe i got there and
it's so true and it's like you don't
matter
like at all yeah but you do like you're
still being watched
right you can't do anything but like i
don't know i just
even with margaret when she's like give
me stuff to do like i feel like there's
always things to do like go cut a ribbon
at a school opening or something no
margaret was like i want work like
there's so much [ __ ] to do like
gala state dinners like you could do it
yeah or and the boring stuff too
yeah also um what i thought was
interesting wait no no i
oh james hewitt i didn't get there yet
do you think he's harry's dad i
i mean i've only seen that con like the
picture
theories in the pictures i haven't met
him in the show yet i think it's like
very very possible that
harry is his son and that's why like the
queen is like aren't you and megan want
to go live in toronto like bye you're
not even a part of it like he's not
technically he doesn't have the royal
blood he has diana's blood
but no royal blood oh that's so
interesting like that
conspiracy theory whatever you want to
call it just would answer it would just
make
so much sense for a million different
reasons got it also
the i finished the episode with the
cousins oh so that's what i was talking
about extended members of the royal
family that was awful
oh oh sorry i thought you were talking
about like margaret and andrew no i
didn't want to like spoil anything yeah
no that was awful
awful so i just really feel like a lot
of the episodes were set out to make the
crown look bad
this season and i never felt that way
before yeah that's what i was saying the
last time it's like
i'm not watching through the queen's
lens i'm watching like the
queen through and out it's a different
perspective it's a different perspective
and even her like
beef with margaret thatcher i don't know
where they end up
but it's like i don't know how to feel
yeah and um i watched an interview of
the woman who played
diana and she was like it's really
important that everyone remembers like
this is like a fictionalized script it's
there's a narrative like
because i guess a lot of people they've
gotten some backlash for like some of
the diana portrayals i don't know what
what or how because she was portrayed
very well um
and like on on their press tour like
they've been saying like remember this
is scripted like it's
based in truth but it's still it's just
a little frustrating because
up until this point it's really felt
like it was yes of course it's an
accurate retelling of history yeah like
that there
was no bias but i guess you know that's
not a thing
yeah it's not you know like whatever i
would just like literally pay
a billion dollars to watch the royal
family just like the corps members
watch the crown and just like tell me
what was true or not you know
yeah i just wish i was like i just
there's so much mystery on the wall
yeah yeah for sure okay next story
little tree drama oh is it the tree
drama brought to you by
what day is it thursday
thursday gotta get boots on thursday
today is thursday
you know what that means just in time
for the start of boot season we have
received a few of the new releases
from our friends at thursday boots a
quick reminder if you don't remember
thursday boots they are the new york
city-based startup brand
that designs really really comfortable
high-quality boots and sells them at the
best
direct-to-consumer prices they handcraft
their boots in the same north american
and european facilities
as brands that charge two to four times
the price but by cutting out the retail
markups they offer the highest quality
boots and very accessible price points
and by the way their shoes are so well
made i feel like i get like so many
cheap boots
for the winter and then by next winter
like i can't use them but i'm not going
on my second winter
winter with a pair of thigh-high boots
from thursday boots and they literally
look
amazing like they're such high quality
boots they have great styles i got also
got a pair of um
little white booties with a heel cuz
like that's what the kids are wearing
now and i like want it to be cool
so thirsty boots is very cutting edge
and it's like you're
you're paying for the quality and the
quality is legit legit
if there ever was a year to invest in
more comfortable boots it's this year
if you want fast fashion or shoes that
rarely will make it out of your closet
do not shop at thursday boots thursday
boots is an investment in comfort
timeless styles and staples that will
last for years and they make great great
men's shoes because we saw a friend of
ours over the weekend
whose boyfriend used our code for
thursday boots yes
you deserve more comfortable boots
without the high retail markups great
gift for someone
yes because thursday boots is all about
year-round honest prices at the lowest
sustainable markup
be possible they never have sales or
discounts but
they're giving our listeners free
two-day shipping on their first order
and always offer free returns and
exchanges
so you have nothing to lose by trying
out your first pair go to
thursdayboots.com
toast and you can have a pair on your
doorstep before next thursday they have
amazing shipping
that's t-h-u-r-s-d-a-y-b-o-o-t-s
dot com slash toast for free two-day
shipping plus free returns
and exchanges love it sign on get your
boots now the t
the tree drama spill the rockefeller
center is defending its 2020 christmas
tree after commenters are poking fun at
its sparse appearance
i am team rockefeller center people are
annoying after making a two-day drive
from oneonta new york the 2020
rockefeller christmas tree
finally arrived in new york city on
saturday however however after sharing
the joyous news on instagram and posing
for a few photos at its new home
the tree was met with some trolling over
its sparse looking branches
these are some of the comments the tree
received quote this tree looks like it
was dragged behind a truck by a chain
then through a fire and extinguished
with sewer water
someone said think the tree has
coronavirus
someone said looks like the ones you buy
at the 99 cent store
some a few other critics said the tree
is the epitome of this past year
this tree looks like 20 20. okay okay
then the tree
responded on instagram saying wow you
almost look great right after a two-day
drive
maybe the tree of personality trees i
just wait until i get my lights on
yeah no every by the way literally every
year when the tree shows up
from i think it's upstate new york it's
it's it's donated from different farms
it's sparsi vibes
really donated rockefeller they can buy
a tree it's sparsi vibes always but they
give the tree like extensions and like
bushels and
lights but like everyone like needs to
just relax like it's not
ready yet and this happens every year
they're like oh this is 20 20 i'm like
no it literally looked this way when it
arrived in 2019 2018 2017.
it's always sparsi vibes but they make
it nice yeah but i think like the fact
that
people are coming for the street just
shows like where we've ended up in 2020
we're in such a dark place
for people places plants trees plants
people's places and plants
it's terrible this is disgrace leave the
[ __ ] tree alone so hurtful you guys
trees have feelings too
no and it's like you know that like the
person who's pharmacist is like so proud
that it's like their tree that made it
to rockefeller center
and him and all the people at work you
mean paula dick who owns daddy al
general store and onion
paula and the gang like drove it down
only to become like a meme like leave
her alone
justice for paula justice for christmas
tree farm where the people are warm
well i can't believe it's been a year
since that song came out and now i get
to like really enjoy the winter season
wow
with it i totally forgot that like it's
it's here you know that's what i'm
trying to tell it's actually one of my
favorite like original christmas songs
not just because it's tails
it's a bop like you could [ __ ] you
could break it down to that song like it
has a beat
and it's just lit i totally agree also
this saga reminds me of the hallmark
original film miss christmas
one of the best ones with um the woman
from
brooke from brookdale orsay she's from
drop dead diva
oh and she's from georgia i can't
believe you didn't like drop dead i
absolutely hated it i can't even talk
about it because i don't want to hurt
your feelings because it's literally a
show that like really changed my life i
know and it
it it was not it for me speaking of
hallmark movies jonathan bennett
aka aaron samuels from mean girls is
starring in a hallmark movie is it
hallmark or is it lifetime
or is it ion well it's a gay couple so
it's probably not hallmark because
they're
it might be i i saw the story too but i
just i just wanted to see i thought it
was so exciting like gay couple it is
exciting let me double check
just confirm that it's hallmark because
no you're totally right it's lifetime
everyone's on the
hallmark grind like that movie the
christmas end was actually
a lifetime movie not a hallmark movie oh
it's horrible
wow sorry i didn't mean to speak ill of
uh
no i'm sorry that i doubted hallmark no
it's called
um yeah it's the first lgbtq plus
hallmark i mean
girl it's 20 20. like that took a really
long time but it's happening and it's
wonderful
halloween yeah that means hallmark
channel released its 2020 slate of
content
and one of them is called
christmas house love it it's jonathan
bennett's third hallmark channel
original movie alongside robert buckley
anna ayore do you know any of these
people
treat williams and sharon lawrence no
maybe if i saw a picture
the film focuses on a gay couple looking
to adopt their first child and airs on
sunday oh it's out already oh wait no
november 22nd
no next that's the sunday okay i know
what we're doing that's so exciting
that is very exciting and we have that
new hulu one with kristen stewart so
it's like
the christmases movies are just becoming
more inclusive i feel like
for a while like nobody cared about like
all the money and effort like hallmark
was putting into their movies
yeah no but it became well i think a lot
of people were always watching
the hallmark it was really the heart of
christmas um
but now everyone's talking about it so
they've stepped up their game and it's
become cool to be like an actor
in them becca tobin was in it uh-huh and
again competition is great for the
consumer great for the consumer and i'm
a consumer at heart
here's the fifth and final story about
competition being a few years too late
twitter has added a new disappearing
tweet feature
called fleets where it's pretty much
stories
like snapchat stories or instagram
stories on twitter uh
what is it five years after this
invention came out
did we learn nothing from like facebook
trying to give us
stories like it was so embarrassing for
them i think they actually got rid of it
like
didn't even mention it because it was
such a failure like
this is honestly like i'm embarrassed
for twitter like this is
really embarrassing so embarrassed like
not only is it embarrassing to copy
something
anytime you're gonna copy because it's
like okay i didn't have the original
thought i copied
at least if you're gonna copy make it
quick yeah no it's like this is
literally we've been i've been on
snapchat since like
20 2010 because i think i started no way
yeah yeah because um no i'm sorry 2014
when i graduated
my senior year of college yeah so it's
like this is so embarrassing like i'm
honestly like red in the face for
twitter like
this is this is a disgrace and honestly
like they should be ashamed of
themselves like truly
yeah like nobody asks for this i don't
think anybody
wants this and i think it's just it's
like deeply deeply sad
and like it's so problematic for so many
reasons like i can't even begin
to explain to people like why this is
such a bad idea yeah
but twitter fleets and you needed to
share your story to twitter
when i heard this i went to our twitter
to like see if anyone was doing it and
there was one person and i want you to
guess who
i went to the morning twitter no she
might have put one up but the first
person i saw who was like
for the the majority of the morning was
the only person who had one
pop crave nick jonas interesting it was
embarrassing for him too
like if you're a celebrity listening to
the show which i'm sure there's you know
tons
don't embarrass yourself like stay off a
fleet oh and the name
actually kind of i don't hate the name
because it's fleeting
fleet is a brand of enemas for your ass
fleet is a weak
fleet week have you ever had panama
yes i know you don't like to talk about
it um no i have like not in my adult
life
but oh really of course as a child i've
had one in my adult life most
most recently made me like four years
ago i feel like you love an enema
i feel like you and they are just like
should we enema tonight oh my god i
already hate enemas you want to know why
because it's like the seven minutes you
have to wait you know like the game
seven minutes in heaven when you were a
kid like the seven minutes that you wait
for an enema to like
marinate your duty is literally seven
minutes in hell
it is so painstakingly awful like it's
that's the worst part and the relief the
relief at the end is great
but is it worth the seven minutes in
hell i don't know
i don't know damn damn all right tv
recap let's talk about real housewives
of salt lake city first because
um i need the will to live and i don't
have but you're like a nerd
he dropped all of his books that is so
mean i'm looking for our bruce add of
course it's the one
oh we could do it by heart at this point
look at these bad boys teeth
bruce is just the tooth bruise you need
if you want to get your teeth in check
all right the best electric toothbrush
on the market the best gift for someone
this holiday season
we've been using them for months they're
so cute they're we got the like
millennial
pastel pleni pink one looks great on
your counter has a magnetic holder comes
with extra travel heads you
uh you can buy travel sets it's just the
most brilliant product if you want to
cultivate a vibe in your bathroom a
bruce is a great place to start cause
it's a beautiful looking toothbrush
so true such great color such a clean
look and i think toothbrushes are some
of like
can be some of like the nastiest element
of your bathroom but not an agreement
but not with bruises like bacteria
shitholes yeah brushing is the best
because brushing your teeth is a chore
but brushing is fun
bruce cleans your teeth at 31 000
movements a minute manual toothbrushes
tap
out at just 300. many electric
toothbrushes are barely a step up for
manual
some of them that do a good job can cost
over 200 dollars
bruce is delivering premier sonic wave
technology without the markups that big
electric toothbrushes
tack on so it's fabulous it's everything
of the sort if you want to get 15 off
for you
someone in your life who you think could
use like an upgrade in the dental
hygiene department
get 15 off your brush when you use promo
code at
promo code toast at bruce.com brucia
spelled b-r-u-u-s-h
so you can try it 90 days risk-free and
get a two-year warranty
at b-r-u-u-s-h dot com promo code toast
for 15
off your order it's really just just
trust us on this one please
yeah also a great gift for someone if
you are looking for gifts in the oral
hygiene
department oh i'm like i lost all my
cards yeah no because you dropped them
on the floor
you got it great okay
let's do salt lake city first because i
honestly like i can't
i'm not ready to talk about the trash
that is orange county and salt lake city
is really
turning out to be something wonderful
yes something wonderful we have a really
the cast is really great everyone is so
different everyone brings something else
to the table
i feel like the crux of last night's
episode was
lisa versus everyone first the cousins
yes oh i love
loving the cousins me too i would say
like right off the bat
heather's one of my favorites if not my
favorite and lisa is really turning into
one miley's favorite no
she quickly became like i feel like when
i just watched the opening credits i was
like oh i'm going to like her yeah she's
like the cutest
like she's so cute she has a tequila
company she seems like she would have
like a sense of humor about her and
she's like
somewhere between she's more than 2.0 so
she's somewhere between like perfect
mormon but also like
drinks and parties and i feel like i
would have thought that we would
gravitate towards her because she seems
like the most
new york like yes and no no but i
actually really like meredith
she's all right no for them from the
first episode i'm like oh meredith is
like fisa
but then i'm like actually you know
meredith is kind of cool and i love that
she just dropped that bomb on us that
her and her husband are separated i know
it's like it's episode two so i don't
care that much about your personal life
yet but it is
interesting but it was weird that they
were talking about it in a crowded
restaurant like
yeah on tv i mean we want the
conversation for tv but like maybe your
living room
you know it's it's obvious that they
have been filming for months
that they are not using any of that
footage because they flash back to
something that happened between
lisa and whitney or whatever like they
have early footage but they decided not
to use it which i actually kind of like
because sometimes at the beginning of
housewives when they just like throw a
bunch of women together like
it takes a minute to get going but them
just like starting six months in i
actually really enjoy so
i think that there was probably other
footage of them um talking about the
separation but they edited it to be like
oh
we're separated yeah which was
interesting i i didn't see that coming
so fast
yeah in at first when whitney was
talking to lisa like
kind of like speaking negatively about
the experience she had with her
gift i was like whitney like this is
really not appropriate even if
you didn't like the service that was
donated to you like just be normal and
talk [ __ ]
like behind your back like don't go up
to your face and be like the bartenders
were drunk they snuck in like
just you asked for a free bar and that's
what you got like
i i didn't appreciate that but then like
lisa took it too far she did take it too
far but i thought that
well okay if those bartenders represent
lisa and her business and
she lisa gave whitney gifts and whitney
what really was coming to her from like
just like she was so grateful but she
was like i just think you should know
like
yeah she was malicious i don't think she
was malicious at all just like saying i
think you should know like the
bartenders you sent got drunk and there
was like something
and they went through my bar and like
that's just something you should know
like
i think that lisa didn't need to know
that what if she uses them other times
what if it's a time when it's an actual
it's not a donated gift someone paid for
that service right i think whitney was
totally fine to tell her that and the
way that she reacted was so awful and
then she started saying like we could
like she's trying to come for our liquor
license like
what yeah no i definitely don't think
whitney came off
in a malicious way but i do also see how
lisa like definitely did not like
one giving someone a gift and then like
kind of getting a little slap in the
face and doing it on camera to like make
her business like look illegitimate like
if
if whitney had sent a text thought if if
lisa handled it better i wouldn't have
thought that made her business look
illegitimate it was just been like oh
we've never used those bartenders before
thank you we'll never use them again and
i would have thought oh wow that's a
good business owner
well at first i was like
feeling more sympathetic toward lisa but
i know for sure
that conversation that happened
off-camera like lisa was being nasty
threatening to say she was a swinger
like
a hundred percent yeah and how
interesting that like i guess modern-day
polygamy is like swinging in utah
that's fabulous yeah it makes sense i
feel bad for whitney like i feel like
she just can't
get out from like this these rumors and
like oh
what people think about her just because
she like got married twice
but i think that this is why the show is
going to be really good for her i really
think that she seems like a real sweet
so sweet i like that she
seems really nice but also will defend
herself like obviously she doesn't seem
super confrontational and i felt like at
the dinner table she really didn't even
want to be having that conversation with
lisa but she also wasn't going to back
down you know
her she was hurt right and and i like
that from her i'm i'm a big fan of hers
and i like
that her and heather are cousins and so
they have each other's backs
and it's like i feel like
it's funny because i feel like i
couldn't be more dissimilar from
heather yeah and whitney but like on a
human level i just like relate to their
emotions
i actually like feel for heather because
i feel like and i don't know like the
salt lake city social scene but i feel
like lisa's like a cool mean girl you
know yeah
and i feel like heather just wants like
to be acknowledged and like she
literally can't even get that from
lisa like i think lisa's like the
definition like i know who lisa is i
can't explain it like you know girls
like that
especially when they talk about like
that kind of judgmental vibe that
she gives off to people like because
she's like a good mormon and like maybe
whitney's not or heather's not
and you know people like that there's
people like that in all religions who
like are
like sanctimonious because they're you
know observing more than you and it's
like
so and it goes against like everything
in the religion like you being a [ __ ]
like
i know that vibe so well so like i
actually
really feel for heather and whitney and
i'm a hundred percent on their side
yeah and also lisa like her way of
arguing is like when the whole thing
happened with the bar
at the wedding vow renewal she was like
well i'm a generous person like i'm done
with this it's like just because you say
it
like like you still have to deal with it
she was like like
she was just like at the table just like
trying to tell us who she is but just
show us
so true you know so true um mary in the
beginning of the episode was
really [ __ ] happy i love mary that's
so funny i don't and i feel like people
love her
she's bothering me so much like she's
just like really
i don't know what the word is but like
eccentric sure she's just saying like
but i like her because i've never seen
anyone like her
on television like and i just find that
interesting even the way she was like
obviously her personal life is
very interesting very well we haven't
even scratched the surface of that
but even the way she was participating
in the dinner fight well that's
like chiming in like jen shaw did not
say one thing i know an interesting
tactic to take mary was like chiming and
just trying to like glaze over she's
like
i just like her energy because it's
different at the beginning of the
episode when she's like going
nuts with jen shawn she's like in
janja's bedroom just like apologize like
she was really bothering me there with
her crazy dress but she looked
fabulous at the ski slope she was
probably best dressed and then she heard
a little commentary during the dinner
that didn't really involve her i thought
she was
very funny so yeah i can't get a read on
her i feel like there's many sides to
marry
i like that i don't want someone who's
just like a textbook housewife who i
like can read in five minutes and i know
how you're gonna act
yeah um also i think whitney's dad is
like a p john
like i actually feel bad for him yeah
and i think she's so she's so sweet
about the whole thing she's a really
nice girl and i also think it was so
nice of mary
to invite um them to her them to her
church
and i just i'm really liking the show
i'm really liking like learning about
like the subculture that is mormonism
even though like
from what i've seen from like people on
social media who are mormon or who live
in utah
or even like heather on watchtrap and
live last night like she said like the
people in utah
are like really excited about housewives
like they're really just like jazz to be
included
but like the people in the mormon church
like don't think that like especially
her
ex-husband who's like a big deal in the
church like doesn't think that this is
the way like the mother of his children
like should be behaving even though like
she's acting nicely
i agree um we saw heather's house yes
even though i got a couple dms that
she lives in park city where um like in
park city proper
where you can't film so it might be like
a fake staged rental house oh that's
on the outside also have you seen this
drama
um i guess it's drama that jen shot
rents
her house shot so [ __ ] annoying no
like
it i don't even think that's so cra like
dramatic but apparently i rent so what
no but apparently like it got out there
and like she's like so
offended that it's out like there's some
drugs interesting
i didn't see that but that is definitely
something good to know
yeah um also
i think you're talking about in terms of
like the mormon community and how they
feel about it
stories from rachel parcell oh who by
the way
like so everyone sent us her stories to
watch because she commented on real
houses of salt lake city and how they
don't have even one active
in the church mormon on the show and so
they're not even and she actually said
that the term mormon is actually like a
derogatory term no mormonism
and that's not how they refer to
themselves i have recently
fallen in love with rachel parcell i
know she's a blogger who's like
literally the first blogger ever and
like i'm late to the game
but olivia sent me her stories and was
like watch this about salt lake city
housewives
and something about like the shirt that
she was wearing and like the breast milk
on her shirt and just like her being
like a mom like and just like doing it
all like
i like fell in love with her i'm like
obsessed with her content is like so
premium and like i just want to live in
utah
and have her husband's company like
build me a house on a mountain like i'm
obsessed
100 and not only it's like you follow
her yes i followed her she's so
interesting
then she has three sisters who also
influence
and i was just like i had heard of them
before but i i never like fell down the
rabbit hole right
i'm i'm down there no me too and it's
just like this life like
whatever presents she's using a [ __ ]
dream no i know like i'm
i'm obsessed but i thought her um
stories were super interesting too
um and honestly just part of me is like
like feels
bad for mormons like not that they need
my sympathy or anything but i just feel
like
every time they're portrayed and like
have representation in like movies or tv
shows like it's just
bad yeah i don't know i don't know if
the solution is to actually
have a an active but i don't know if you
can
yeah so that's why they don't get to
portray themselves in movies and tv
shows and so it's just
heather said that it's very she's not
excommunicated from the church
yet that's what she said but it's very
possible by the end of the season like
she will be
interesting she's like on the fringe she
like does her own thing but like still i
think it's technically part
but i don't think she's like devout got
it well it's
it's shaping up to be really good
because there's so many different
elements i love the fact that they were
meredith is jewish
yes like actively jewish actively lisa
was was born jewish but converted okay
um i love that they went skiing like fun
you know it kind of made me want to go
skiing
but also like the torture of the bags
and the skis i was like
my arms hurt already no just watching i
know that feeling like of hiking up with
all your [ __ ]
yeah but they were so fabulous on the
mountain like whitney and heather and
meredith are insane skiers no i know it
like kind of made me want to learn how
to ski but then i remember the one time
i did like my shins were
broken oh yeah they'll kill your shins
but you know now we have to go skiing i
kind of want to go snowboarding you
think i'll be good at it
i think snowboarding from what i've
heard it's easier to learn
snowboarding but like harder to master
well because like the thing with skiing
is like the two poles the two skis
clinging into each other
it's like so much equipment where it's
like one big snowboard like that seems
easier to me
i don't know i think maybe i should try
it okay we've gotta take a trip
we've go no every time i watch real
housewives of salt lake city i'm like
why am i not in utah yeah
i just i really am enjoying it so much
it's really well done
they have a really great group of women
and i'm completely here for it like i i
look forward to it me too it's a treat
it's a sweet treat
at the end of a long day speaking of
things i'm not looking forward to is
real houses orange county and i think we
should talk about
real housewives of orange county before
we do the recap and its place on this
show
yeah i feel as though we tried
and i really don't want to reward bad
content with my time
and my viewership and my platform and
it's not even that like now we have salt
lake city it's another thing to add to
the content plate
and i think that something has to be
taken off the plate my plate runs over
my plate run it's over i agree and
i think i like at one point in my life
like i could be the girl who watched
all the franchises and i don't think i
can be that girl anymore like i don't
know
i have a son i don't sense that like
stanhood obsession
of orange county from the toasters if i
if we did
we'd be not saying this no and actually
that reminded me um because there are a
lot of people who listen to our recaps
but don't necessarily watch housewives
because it's so intimidating to get into
and i really recommend everyone starts
with salt lake city because there's only
two episodes and you could start at the
ground floor
with us and you can keep up with the
recaps and it's actually
very good yeah so uh we can recap last
night's episode of oc but
i think moving forward i think i'm out i
think moving forward it is
an optional viewing if you happen to
watch it
you want to talk about it fine but like
i was revolving my night around last
night and
it was just not deserving of that um
agreed and you know last week i really
had only had one thing to contribute to
the oc um recap which was that i thought
the scene in bronwyn's bedroom with her
son trying out drag was like really
inspirational and like a great message
to send and funnily enough i think the
only
scene worth re-hashing on last night's
episode was the scene where her son
went ballistic at the bow renewal and
said like the craziest [ __ ] when he was
asked to speak
it was so inappropriate and
uncomfortable and
unnecessary and i just i don't know like
like i just know like there are certain
kids like who
like who were raised a certain way who
know like if you ever said something
like that in public like
you were getting [ __ ] slapped back
home like i don't know
what came over him like to say such a
bizarre thing
twice yeah two bizarre things two
bizarre things it was so
weird it was so weird i agree the trip
actually that hotel looks super nice and
like i actually
really wanted to like be in palm springs
yeah it
it looks all right um i don't know it
looks like torture like drive up
weddings at night the coronavirus like
element of it all is like i just don't
want it no it's like it's sneaking in
and i can't i'm not going back there
like obviously i'm not watching no i'm
not going back there like i know that
they were the first franchise to like
film with masks and like
i'm triggered by it like to a really
dark time in my life oh and also and i
think this just like
sent me the fact that shannon storms the
door
is freaking out over kelly saying that
she's starting a water line as opposed
to a tincture
no no it's so no it's so irrelevant
she went so ham like talking at the
ceremony talking after the ceremony like
she's so upset by it and it's like no
it's really not that big of a deal and i
know i'm not supposed to but i'm sorry i
really like kelly dodd
she's one of the reasons like i still
watch the show like she is funny like
and i know everyone thought she was
being insensitive to bronwyn but making
the comparison of
not having sugar at your wedding because
you're diabetic was actually funny
like i really like kelly god i like
again she's someone you don't see very
often she has absolutely no filter she
is like
so offensive so unapologetic and it is
so interesting to watch and you know i
actually feel like she's come a long way
because she used to say the craziest
[ __ ]
and now it's like kelly's unfiltered
she's making jokes about like alcohol
and diabetes and it's like
that's nothing that's like a three on
the kelly dodd scale she used to be wild
she really has and i know no one gives
her credit because she's still
unfiltered
but she has tamed herself quite a bit
yeah no i think it's hysterical and like
everyone was gonna drink tequila that
weekend and kelly does the only one
who's gonna own like who's gonna walk in
the door with it like
it turns out shannon on watch robin's
live andy said he's literally never seen
a funnier episode
than next week shannon storms the door
at this reception
is blacked out like he's never she said
she doesn't remember anything
that's so weird so it's like you were
the one saying that kelly's insensitive
yeah you're the one who drank all the
tequila right right he's running back to
him
he's like being upfront about it and i i
just
i i i'm i don't hate her
no i don't hate her either but i feel
like i should you know
um still stan emily till the day i die
and gina i just can't with another thing
about bronwyn
i i feel like last season i felt this
way she's brand new she's bringing all
of her family drama on the show
it's not interesting even if it's
someone i like love and have known for
years but especially on your first
season like i really don't care
um and i feel like now this season
everything is just so heavy with her
like
the alcoholism and the sobriety and it's
a lot and then it's like again with the
mom like
and i just i can't care everyone's
family has drama and it's like
we're busy worrying about our own family
drama i can't care about bronwyn's
no it's like that it's like everything
she's doing is so heavy
yeah i i totally agree and i don't care
about like
the mom and that weird house like i just
i don't
actually the story behind that was like
kind of interesting but um
yeah again i don't care and like
bronwyn's mom like wearing a necklace
it's like
be kind and then she's like being so
[ __ ] mean to her daughter no she's
really nasty like
by the way and i agree like if if that
like i understand bronwyn wanting to
talk about it like she's traumatized by
her mother her mom telling tamara
that bronwyn was sober before like
broadway got to tell anyone is one of
the most [ __ ] up things ever like her
mom is
awful but like yeah i still don't care
no and like bro like
bronwyn should stop filming with her
like stuff yes making her a part of the
mix she would have never
met tamara i thought the same thing like
just
remove yourself from the situation yeah
but like she's driving to her house and
putting her on camera like
she only fuels the dr deb machine
yeah but i really have nothing else to
say and i i do think in this instance of
our renewal
is not a curse for the two of them one
because they've already renewed their
vows beforehand too because like
they are soul mates and yeah everything
they really are in the most annoying way
and their family with all of their kids
like is just so cute they really remind
me of like cheaper by the dozen
yeah that's a good call um so yeah
this might be our last oc uh recap let
us know like if there's like
so much like support and outpouring
asking people to continue like
i would be open to it but i just don't
think that's gonna happen no i don't
think so either and i'm just so over it
and like
sometimes you have to take care of
yourself and sometimes that involves not
watching real housewives of orange
county
amen so that's our episode we'll be back
tomorrow for our final episode of the
week and our merch drop reminder our
merch
holiday new collections phone cases mugs
sweatshirts sweatshirts zip ups sweaters
whatever
uh all available on shopmorningtoast.com
tomorrow at 10 30 a.m eastern time
so we will post all of the items on our
instagram make sure you're following us
on the morning toast and
that's all we got that's all we got also
next week we are off
the monday through friday the week of
thanksgiving
but if you want more content from us
monday tuesday wednesday we'll be doing
podcast only episodes for our patreon
patreon.com slash the morning toast so
head over there subscribe you also get
access to all the episodes we've done
previously
it's just a really premium place and
that's where you can hear from us if
you'll be feeling rdh that we are off
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitch or public radio
ihop radio cast box
all the places so ever you listen to
podcast find us the morning toast and
leave a five-star review about how
beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an amazing day stay safe and we
will see you tomorrow for friday
goodbye goodbye